For as long as human beings have walked upon
the Earth, and looked up to the night sky
at the vast, inky darkness of space, we’ve
pondered a particular question over and over
again: are we truly alone in the universe?
Surely, it can’t be just us, right?
The stars and planets stretch out so vastly
beyond the confines of our little blue world,
it seems that there’s at least enough room
up there for some other forms of life to exist.
But if they do, if there’s someone… or
something out there, would they be friend
or foe?
Would an alien race be sympathetic to the
plights of humanity?
Or would they perhaps view us as a hostile
threat, something to be wiped out before we
have the chance to do the same to them?
How would such a race even go about introducing
itself to us?
With a swift attack?
A grandiose emerging from space?
Or maybe they’d try something far subtler,
a subterfuge, observing us from a distance,
watching, learning, all while hidden in plain
sight.
To answer these questions posed throughout
the ages, the ideas that have inspired generations
of science-fiction writers, perhaps we should
turn our gaze away from the stars.
Let’s start our story by looking instead
at something smaller, something that might
be the exact opposite of the incalculable
vastness of space and all the mysteries it
holds.
This story, like so many others, begins not
up there among constellations, meteors, and
gas giants, but in a small, rural town.
A satellite miles and miles away from the
busy lifestyle of the nearest city.
A place where everyone knows each other’s
face, and where someone…
no, something, has been waiting, watching,
concealed in the one place no-one would expect.
Now, it’s worth remembering, that when you
live in a small town, being a local celebrity
is essentially just the same as infamy.
Saying that you’re ‘really famous in your
hometown’ can be like admitting that you’re
considered the weirdest person in your direct
vicinity.
Sometimes, the people with that mindset wind
up strutting around their tiny township in
the middle of nowhere, under the impression
that they’re God’s gift to every passer-by.
Other times, they garner odd looks and whispered
stories from anyone that spots them.
Gary knew more than his fair share of these
types.
He worked at a small, family-owned convenience
store, one of those places that everyone in
town shopped at.
Now, as any retail worker will tell you, no
one who works in a shop ever really likes
their job.
Ultimately, it’s usually just a way to get
paid with the promise of one day being able
to wave goodbye to the cycle of stacking shelves
and manning the cash register.
And so, trapped in a small-town retail job,
usually stationed in the one spot where he
had to talk to every customer that came through
the door, Gary had seen them all.
From the ordinary and the boring, to the nasty
and unreasonable.
But on the other side of that list were the
people who were just a little bit…
off.
Those customers might look a bit shady, or
act a little bit strange, not enough to draw
everyone’s attention, but still enough to
be noticed.
Almost like they felt uncomfortable in their
own skin.
One of the more infamous customers that Gary
had encountered had garnered one hell of a
reputation with his fellow employees.
They even had a nickname for her: ‘The Duchess’,
as those working in the shop knew her.
She seemed mostly oblivious to other people
around her, until she needed something.
And her way of asking for help was certainly
strange to say the least.
Sometimes she might be rude, or talk without
specifying which of the store’s employees
she was talking to.
But then there were the times when she seemed
to be trying to engage in conversation with
Gary or one of his co-workers.
The Duchess might start out speaking with
most of her own patterns, but would seem to
try to copy the cadence or dialect of whoever
she happened to be talking to.She’d copy
accents, echo back particular phrases or even
other languages, like she was mocking them…
or trying to mimic them.
Naturally, every time she appeared in the
store, Gary and the rest of the staff ran
a mile; or at least hid in the break room
out back until the owner of the store told
them all to get back to work.
But among the employees, caution was always
advised when approaching or providing service
to The Duchess, as if she could snap at a
moment’s notice.
Whenever he saw her, Gary was reminded of
his first encounter with this particular customer.
He had been unlucky enough to be filling shelves
when The Duchess had appeared out of nowhere.
She forced a basket into his hands and instructed
Gary to follow her around the shop and fill
it with items that she specified.
Afterwards, she told him to carry her bags
of shopping outside and fill her car before
she left.
It was as though someone had altered Gary’s
job description to ‘butler’ without telling
him.
No one fully understood why she always acted
so bizarrely.
There were plenty of rumors circulating of
course, ranging from the simple explanation
of ‘she’s from a different generation’
to the more outlandish and wild theories.
While he’d never fully believed in things
like that, Gary always joked that she was
so disconnected because she was actually from
another planet.
Sure, an alien disguised as a human coming
to do their grocery shopping at a small-town
store, sounds impossible right?
Well, maybe.
Around a week since his previous encounter
with the Duchess, Gary noticed another customer
in the store who seemed to be acting just
as unusually.
It was a man this time, wiry and tall, but
hunched over.
When the man had first come into the store,
Gary had spotted him muttering to himself.
Instantly, trapped once again behind the cash
register, he felt his heart drop, immediately
assuming the man might cause trouble.
As he shuffled all around the store, slinking
through the aisles, Gary could overhear him
ranting about… waffles?
The wire-framed man was murmuring about waffles,
how they were a pastry eaten for breakfast
with syrup, how much humans enjoyed them.
Humans, he hadn’t said ‘us’, he had
specifically used the word humans.
The man quickly corrected himself with the
proper word, almost as if he was teaching
himself how to speak.
Naturally, as anyone else working retail would,
Gary assumed the man was inebriated.
As was often the case, no matter how strange
someone in the store was acting, the staff
would ultimately forget all about them by
the time their long, eight-hour shift drew
to a close and they were eventually allowed
to go home.
But maybe it was becoming more frequent, because
for some reason, Gary couldn’t help noticing
even more weird behavior from people all over
town.
Sometimes it’d be somebody he knew, a neighbor,
a dog-walker, the one jogger he’d see on
their way back from the park as he was heading
home after work.
One day, they’d be themselves, the next
they’d be… well, alien.
Every time he spotted one, it seemed that
another would appear the very next day.
Little did Gary know; things were only due
to get even stranger still.
Over the next month, staff from the store
stopped showing up for their shifts.
Gary’s manager was in pieces, trying to
call his employees to find out exactly why
they weren’t notifying him about their unscheduled
absence.
Each one never gave a clear answer.
The more of them stayed home, the longer Gary
found himself having to pick up the slack
and cover their shifts.
At first, when it was just an extra one or
two shifts a week, he didn’t mind so much.
Working more hours meant extra pay.
But as more and more of his colleagues seemed
to disappear without a trace, Gary started
finding himself spending more time at work
than at home, and feeling pretty unhappy about
it, to say the least.
After all, what good is all that extra overtime
pay if you can’t get any time to spend it?
Just as Gary’s exhaustion from having to
work so much was reaching its peak, taking
so much of a toll that he could barely stay
awake at the checkout, that’s when she appeared
again.
The Duchess looked different this time though,
and definitely not as the result of a dramatic
makeover.
Immediately Gary noticed some kind of… growth
swelling out from the Duchess’ shoulder.
He didn’t want to stare – that would be
just as rude if not worse than making a comment
about it – but he was certain it hadn’t
been there before.
On this particular day, The Duchess had seemingly
also decided to be more unreasonable than
usual.
Instead of just making Gary carry her groceries
out to her car again, she was insisting that
he bring them all the way back to her house.
Naturally, Gary told her what any reasonable
person would, explaining calmly that he couldn’t
leave the store during his shift, in the interest
of putting his own safety first.
Wrong move.
The Duchess didn’t seem to understand the
concept, repeatedly stating that this was
“non-negotiable”.
Now, when someone in Gary’s line of work
is faced with an unreasonable and unusual
request, the only person that can come to
their aid is their manager.
Unfortunately, a long debate with the Duchess
was a battle that Gary’s boss just couldn’t
win.
Eventually, after talking in circles with
the Duchess, the store owner folded, telling
his employee to do as she asked while he stayed
behind and watched the cash register.
Begrudgingly, Gary picked up the Duchess’
groceries as she led him out of the store.
Big mistake.
Although it wasn’t far, and Gary wasn’t
really listening, the strange customer seemed
to be talking about a gathering she was hosting,
with a group of local townsfolk waiting at
her home.
Sure, that sounds normal enough for some small-town
folk; when there’s a limited number of people
who live near you, ‘loving thy neighbor’
usually becomes your only option for socializing.
But Gary wasn’t expecting the sight that
awaited him when he arrived at the Duchess’
house.
Just as she had said, there was a huge group
of locals there, all of them milling around
idly, staring at Gary with wide, unnerving
eyes, not blinking as he carried the groceries
indoors.
As if that wasn’t strange enough, almost
all of them seemed to be sporting the same
type of growths as the Duchess, bulging out
of their shoulders or just visible under shirt
collars.
Just like back in the store, Gary tried to
force himself not to stare, never letting
his eyes linger for too long on one of the
silent, staring townsfolk or their strange
protrusions.
But maybe he would have been safer if he’d
stared.
Maybe he would have noticed the group of them
huddling around him, shuffling closer while
his back was turned.
If he stared, he might have spotted the hands,
reaching out towards him.
And he might even have seen what looked like
his co-workers, the friends he had from the
store all huddled at the back of the room.
As far as his boss knew, Gary returned within
a few minutes, followed shortly by the rest
of his staff.
The store owner spent a few minutes angrily
berating them for not showing up to work on
time, not thinking to question where they’d
all been or why they all came back to the
store when Gary did.
Each of his employees simply stood there,
staring at him, hanging off every word like
it was the first time they’d heard a human
being speak.
Or like they were learning how to.
The truth was, neither Gary nor any of his
colleagues made it back to the store that
day.
The… things that came back in their place
only looked like Gary and the others on the
outside.
Just like the other people in town, more and
more of them had been acting strange, speaking
in odd patterns and sporting strange growths
on their bodies.
No one knows how long it took for everyone
to be replaced, some mysterious organization
swept into town a few weeks later.
A number of people… or the things that were
disguised as people, all disappeared soon
after.
Any actual humans that were left behind didn’t
notice, forgetting how many others used to
live in the town, as if they had been drugged.
With the local store closing its doors, and
fewer people around, most of them packed their
belongings and moved on, heading to live elsewhere.
Eventually, the town fell silent.
If you were to pass through there today, you’d
find nothing but the remains of a community
that gradually changed into something… alien.
All that’s left of the place now is a ghost
town.
You might even call it an empty shell.
Few people would ever really understand what
happened in that small, rural town.
Even those who did know would never admit
to it.
The SCP Foundation is like that, as you may
well know.
They’re shady, secretive and would much
rather keep to themselves, not unlike that
group of townsfolk, actually.
Well, that is, after they’d each been replaced
by an instance of SCP-3994.
The thing no one dares to ask about humanity
looking up to the stars for so many centuries,
is what if someone up there was looking back
at us?
What if, for the entire lifetime of our civilization,
there’s been a race of alien creatures attempting
to study us, venturing to our backwater, small
town of a planet, and taking the form of humans
for some nefarious purpose?
Meet SCP-3994, that is, if you haven’t already
been acquainted with one of them.
They could be anyone, the local celebrity
in your small town, a person who you pass
on the street every day, even a wild animal.
You see, SCP-3994 refers to a race of extraterrestrials,
beings not of our world, and a currently unknown
number of them have been cataloged by the
SCP Foundation.
SCP-3994s tend to hide in plain sight, through
the use of convincing human skin disguises,
or ‘shells’.
Well, while these shells might start by looking
convincing, in actual fact they’re far from
perfect.
Almost seventy percent of SCP-3994 shells
experience some form of rapid degradation,
and this causes the imperfections in their
disguises to shine through.
A deteriorating human shell usually results
in a number of physical deformities.
An SCP-3994 instance wearing its shell might
appear as someone with a limb that twists
and bends in an unnatural way, but showing
no signs of actually noticing it.
Alternatively, a person who seems to have
a skeleton that doesn’t match their external
bodily proportions might also be an extraterrestrial
in hiding.
And then, there’s the growths that some
SCP-3994 shells have.
These are severe malformations that resemble
elephantiasis: a medical condition that causes
certain areas of the body to enlarge.
But just looking out for these tells isn’t
a sure-fire way of spotting one of these aliens.
Not all their shells have the same levels
of decay, in fact, the Foundation has developed
sub-categories of SCP-3994 instances based
on how noticeable their shells are.
Category A are SCP-3994s whose shells are
almost impossible to detect, practically resembling
human beings one to one.
On the other side, are the Category Cs, which
are members of the same extra-terrestrial
species without shells.
And between them, in Category B, are the ones
whose shells are showing signs of decay.
Another method the SCP Foundation has used
to detect instances of SCP-3994 is speech.
In almost forty percent of conversations,
these aliens will attempt to mimic the speech
patterns of the human they are conversing
with.
This can be as blatant as SCP-3994s echoing
back elements of speech as hard to replicate
as regional accents and dialects, different
languages, or specific phrases unique to the
person they’re copying.
While in some instances SCP-3994s have shown
difficulty with grammar and syntax at first,
they seem to be quick learners.
Couple that with the almost-perfect shells
in Category A, and these alien visitors could
prove to be formidable infiltrators.
Researchers even discovered telepathic communications
between instances.
Eventually, though, all SCP-3994 shells do
inevitably decay.
This usually takes around a year, as their
human disguises gradually dissolve until the
creature beneath is eventually exposed.
That’s where the various protrusions, misshapen
body parts, and other signs of decay come
from.
It’s not that SCP-3994s are intentionally
walking around with noticeable shells, it’s
that they can’t prevent their shells from
eventually withering away until their true
self is put on display.
And what do they look like under their disguises?
Are they tall, slender, grey-skinned beings
with long heads?
Are they tiny little green men piloting human-sized
robot suits?
Could they even be bulbous creatures of living
calcium with huge claws, kept concealed and
compressed in skin suits with zippers hidden
under their hairlines?
Well, no, to all of these.
That’d be terribly cliche, don’t you think?
Beneath their rapidly decaying shells is a
viscous, pulp-like substance, of formless
and unquantifiable composition.
Without their disguises, SCP-3994 have no
regular shape, no skeleton or body structure.
Underneath, each of them is just an indeterminate
mass that drags itself around aimlessly.
So, the one question that remains is… why?
Why come to Earth?
Why replicate and replace innocent humans?
Why spend so much time trying to learn how
to blend in as a part of our civilization
- like sinister imposters among us?
Well, the ones in Foundation captivity seem
to be pretty eager to leave.
During multiple incidents, they have been
known to create shells that mimic the appearance
of security staff, scientists, and other Foundation
personnel in order to orchestrate their escape.
All the while, they’ve been showing themselves
capable of learning how to impersonate human
speech and mannerisms.
But what is it all for?
The best answer is, we don’t know.
Or rather, we don’t know yet.
Could they be here to study humanity?
Do these SCP-3994s want to learn how to be
more like us for their own benefit?
Think about it, if you had no shape, no body,
if you were just a formless mass, wouldn’t
you feel a little…
lonely?
SCP-3994, like humans, might be social animals.
The difference is we can hug each other, high-five
each other, converse, form meaningful connections
through talking and touch.
It could be that’s what these extra-terrestrial
imposters want, why they decided to venture
across the stars to live among us.
That’d be nice, right?
But then there’s the other explanation.
SCP-3994 are an alien army hiding out on Earth,
learning more and more about us day by day.
The more they learn, the better they’ll
get at copying us, walking, talking, and acting
no different from any other human.
The Foundation doesn’t even know just how
many are out there.
Soon, they could have perfectly mimicked every
language, every culture, every person on Earth.
And what happens then?
What happens when we all get replaced?
Well, at that point, the planet would no longer
belong to us.
It would be the new home for SCP-3994.
Now go check out “SCP-2086 Man Eating Bus”
and “SCP-939 With Many Voices - The Complete
Story” for more anomalies that are hiding
in plain sight!